in part one of the series we learned
about how Syrians have been immigrating
to the US for more than a hundred years
in part two I'll explore my own parents
integration story my mom and dad are
immigrants in this country making my
siblings and I the children of
immigrants when we were kids we would
make fun of our parents accents I
couldn't understand why my dad in
particular had trouble pronouncing the
words girl or world he would say good
old and what oh I also didn't know that
his organs from Syria my parents worked
day and night to learn English and went
through a lot of trouble to come to the
u.s. today Assyrians are vilified by the
media and politicians I decided it was
fun to go home to talk to my mom and dad
about why they decided to come here and
what's probably fake I wasn't sure I was
going to make it very medical and I
still have a feeling I'm afraid or fall
sick of what's going to happen to me and
I thought maybe we can start a new life
and then we may be back my father a
doctor came to Houston Texas in 1981 he
realized that most of the successful
doctors in Syria had been trained in the
u.s. so he came here for a better
education my mother joined him a few
years later and they made their home in
Worcester Massachusetts when my parents
first came here they went to night
classes to learn English they spoke with
an Arabic accent but they always knew
that their future kids were going to
speak both languages without seeing
action that's a tall order for a kid who
just wanted to play with his Sega
Genesis
when you go out people go in yes you
will for me this is so much not fair and
there were studies two languages and why
you would believe this lower self
nevertheless every summer
my parents took me and my four siblings
back home to Damascus I studied Arabic
for 11 summers in Syria my parents never
expected to stay in the US 12 the
temporary things though
well you know that's going to obscure
the earth most five years until I finish
my training might have been seen my
fellowship and then I we would go back
but things changed my parents ultimately
chose stay and make America their home
to give us their children the best
possible opportunities and you roll it
little yeah and then you go all the way
good job you have to put the extra
effort in making your kids identify what
they are learning get the language of
their ancestors come back and try to
know their religion also my parents got
their wish so far anyway my sister
Stella just had her first child sitting
and as the first time uncle I want to
make sure that she grows to love her
culture
what I most shirts like my parents for
is the guts it took to leave everything
behind act their bags board an airplane
and accept that they may never live in
their home country again there ever a
moment when you just wanted to pack up
all your stuff and just go back I was
homesick I miss my mom I never thought
about the challenges of acclimating and
assimilating that while you're adjusting
to new streets and customs and
communities they're adjusting to you too
and they might not like what they see
today and share with you a story when I
thought you showed a lot of courage when
we were together we were shopping in the
folder man walked by you and he said
some people just don't get it and you
looked at him and then he put him to
shut up
their face and I thought that was the
bravest thing in the world yet some
people try to make fun of you because
they think that you don't know you don't
understand them living in this country
you have to be courageous you have to be
you have to put your step and ten and
show everybody that come here I'm just
like everybody I remember gotten your
fixation today in America yes yeah but
when you show me those tears I felt so
bad what should you have to you my
criteria are you guys the first time
here I'm thankful to this computer to
give us the opportunity here to be who
we want to be so we came home a little
people nowadays my parents on their own
school which teaches kids to write read
and speak Arabic it's their way of
preserving the Arabic language within
their community give us this passion to
see all of all the graduates you know
come and make Bank of today there's
another cause that they feel very
strongly about refugees we need to help
the people who are coming from Syria now
because we really have nobody to help
them or they have very little help not
acceptable and not safe
and what did they do with feeding people
what did they do
looking around I felt grateful for the
opportunities my parents had afforded us
I thought of the Syrian refugees have
recently come to the u.s. and faced many
of the same challenges my parents
overcame but under very different
circumstances so I'm like my Syrian
family which immigrated in a time of
peace and stability next we'll hear from
a family that fled when war reach their
doorstep
we'll hear about how they made it out of
Aleppo and what they found when they
reach the US as refugees make sure you
watch till the end